bien estamos en el problema número 16 el
problema número 16 y fíjate que tiene un
dibujo parecido a éste que de una vez ya
me adelanté hacerlo tiene un dibujo en
el cual tenemos un cuadrado y este
cuadrado tiene tres unidades de longitud
por lado ok ahora dentro de este
cuadrado hay otro cuadrado este de aquí
y nos dan algunos datos por ejemplo nos
dicen que estos sean los que se forman
son de 90 grados este es de 90 grados es
también de 90 grados este también y es
también y todos ellos tienen aquí una
base de dos unidades mientras que tienen
una altura de una unidad o al revés si
lo quieres ver aquí hay una unidad y
aquí hay dos unidades dos unidades una
unidad etcétera etcétera
2 y 1 y lo que me preguntan es cuánto
vale el área de lo que tengo aquí
sombreado cuánto vale el área de esto
que está aquí ok ahora para responder
esta pregunta pues hay varios
procedimientos pero a mí se me ocurre
que el procedimiento que más nos
serviría para entender este problema es
a trazar rectángulos fíjate bien yo
tengo aquí un triángulo pero qué pasa si
este triángulo de aquí acá construyó un
rectángulo con esta altura y con esta
misma base pues me va a quedar algo así
y si de la misma manera hago un
rectángulo de aquí hasta acá pues no va
a quedar algo muy parecido a esto estás
de acuerdo y ahora voy a hacer lo mismo
un rectángulo de aquí hasta acá y me va
a quedar algo así fíjate que esto es la
mitad de este triángulo que está fuera
del área que yo quiero saber su área y
la mitad está adentro formando un
triángulo que es exactamente igual al
triángulo que está fuera y si yo me
tengo ahora este pues me va a quedar lo
mismo
un rectángulo parecido a éste
lo primero que quiero preguntarte lo
primero que quiero saber es cuánto vale
el área de esta parte que tengo aquí
adentro cuánto va a valer el área de
este cuadrado que tengo aquí adentro
bueno pues lo que quiero que te des
cuenta es que este cuadrado que tengo
aquí adentro tienen como lado 1 porque
porque aquí tengo a dos unidades de aquí
tengo una unidad por lo tanto de aquí
acá debe de haber una unidad y de igual
manera para acá aquí tengo dos unidades
y entonces si de aquí hay una unidad de
que acá también debe de haber una unidad
y etcétera etcétera es exactamente el
mismo razonamiento por lo tanto si cada
uno de los lados de este cuadrado tiene
una unidad del árbol entonces el área de
este rectángulo es de una unidad el área
es de uno de este de este cuadrado que
tengo aquí adentro ahora como no sacamos
el área de lo que nos falta que también
está coloreado como no sacamos el área
de esto que tengo aquí bueno pues si te
das cuenta el área que tengo aquí se
repite cuatro veces esta área de clima
que está área de clima que está área de
aquí que estaré aquí por lo tanto qué te
parece calculamos solamente una
y bajo esa la multiplicamos por cuatro
entonces me voy a fijar ahorita
solamente en esta área que tengo aquí
voy a cambiar de color y me voy a fijar
en esta que tengo aquí ahora el área que
tengo aquí a date cuenta que la podemos
obtener como la mitad de este rectángulo
de este rectángulo de 2 y 1 que tiene
una base de 1 y una altura de 2 por lo
tanto por lo tanto este triángulo de
azul déjame ponerlo con el mismo color
este triángulo de azul tiene como área
la mitad un medio de pues el área del
rectángulo y el área del rectángulo es
la base por la altura ahora está
rentando tiene como base una unidad y
como altura dos unidades por lo tanto el
área va a ser igual
en medio de uno por dos los cuales dos y
dos por un medio me va a dar uno el área
de esa parte de azul es una unidad el
área de esta parte de azul es una unidad
el área de esto es por una unidad ok
ahora esa es el área de esta parte de
azul pero esta parte es exactamente
igual que esta parte por lo tanto
también va a tener un área de una unidad
va a tener la misma área y esta parte
también también va a tener una unidad de
área y esta parte esta parte también va
a tener una unidad de área en una
comunidad de área por lo tanto toda la
parte que está coloreada cuántos
usuarios
vamos a cambiar a este color el área de
la parte coloreada va a ser igual a uno
a este uno más uno a este uno más uno
más este uno más
+ 1 que es estar acá abajo ya eso le voy
a sumar 1 que es este uno del área del
cuadrado que tengo aquí el centro y esto
es igual a uno más uno más uno más uno
más uno lo cual es cinco el área de lo
que tengo que adentro coloreado es igual
a cinco y bueno esta se me ocurre una
forma para resolver este problema tal
vez en ti se te ocurra otra forma para
resolver el mismo problema y estaría
bien podría saber sacar el área total y
después de estar de esta área sombreada
o restarle el área de cada uno de sus
triángulos no sé pero bueno hay varias
formas de resolver este mismo problema
el problema en tener como solución 5 ok
problemas 16 vamos a ser el problema de
17 ponemos todo esto y vamos a hacer
ahora el problema
1717 ok
dice para todos los enteros positivos jk
definimos a este tipo de problemas me
encantan cuando tiene operaciones raras
j
cuadrado r cuadrado r que es igual al
residuo en residuo
que encontramos al dividir jota entre
acá al dividir jota entre cam ok o si
hacemos la división de jota entre camps
y el residuo va a ser igual a jota
cuadrado con r
a ver si me explico un poco imagínate
que tengamos a no sé 5 a 5 r2 bueno pues
lo que tendríamos que hacer es calcular
la división de 5 entre 2 de 52 me cabe
dos veces 2 por 24 sobre 1 y este es el
residuo por lo tanto mi
resultado de la operación 5 r2 es igual
a 1 porque es el residuo es el residuo
que obtenemos de dividir 5 entre 2 ok
hasta aquí creo que vamos bien ahora que
es lo que me preguntan lo que quieren
saber
si 13
cuadrado
r si 13 cuadrado
es igual a 2 ok lo que me preguntan es
cuánto vale
cuánto vale que si cumplen que acá es el
número que se pone aquí en la operación
13 cuadrado r acá igualados ok que
quiere decir esto está un poco confuso
pero realmente no está tan difícil si lo
visualizamos de la siguiente manera esta
expresión de aquí esta expresión de aquí
por definición es exactamente lo mismo
que quiere a pues estoy diciendo que
cuando nosotros dividimos al 13 entre
acá vamos a obtener algo y nuestros
residuos va a ser 2 ahora acá es un
entero positivo y el residuo el residuo
sí
duo siempre tiene que ser más grande que
será más grande que 0 y menor que es el
número que está dividiendo y menorca
esto por el algoritmo de la división el
residuo puede ser 0 es un número que es
mayor que 0 es positivo pero tiene que
ser menor que k ok a ver pensemos un
poco qué número cuando divide a 13
obtenemos un residuo de 2
a ver pensemos si tenemos por ejemplo
que acá vale 3 los 3 a 3
veamos 3
cabe 4 veces 4 por 3 12 y sombra 1 por
lo tanto no tengo un residuo de 2
2 tampoco
34 tampoco 5 tampoco
6 tampoco 7 tampoco 8 tampoco 9 tampoco
y de hecho la respuesta si ya te diste
cuenta es 11 11 es el único número tal
que si nos tomamos la división de 3
entre 11 cabe una vez 1 por alces 11 y
sobran 2 y este es el único número que
deja residuos 2 y bueno lo podemos
resolver de simple inspección fijándonos
en los números menores de 13 por lo
tanto camps el valor de camps es igual a
11 porque es el único número que cuando
nos tomamos la división de 3 entre dos
se tiene el de residuo 2 vamos a
afrontarlo aquí 2 es el residuo el
residuo el residuo de tomar los 13 entre
11 que es justo lo que queríamos
perfecto ok bueno pues ya tenemos el
problema número 17 y pues vamos a
resolver el último problema de este de
esta sección aunque es el problema
número 18 y me dice lo siguiente
18 dice el promedio del puntaje de un
cierto examen en un cierto salón con p
estudiantes es de 70 puntos ok eso vamos
a apuntar no creo que es importante si
tengo fe estudiantes
estudiantes entonces el promedio del
puntaje de un cierto examen el promedio
el promedio es a 70 puntos es 70 ahora
esto en este salón después dice en otro
salón de clases o por otra parte el
promedio de n estudiantes es de 92
puntos ok en otro salón tengo en
estudiantes en estudiantes
y tengo un promedio de 92 puntos
promedio estos estudiantes dieron un
mejor promedio apuntaron mejor en esta
prueba ahora después me dice cuando el
promedio de las dos clases se combinan
el promedio total es 86 ok cuál es el
valor de p / m lo que quiero saber es
cuánto es el valor de p / n ok vamos a
ver que puedo utilizar lo que creo que
primero lo que necesitamos recordar es
que significa el promedio cuando yo me
tomo el promedio de algo el promedio es
igual a la suma a la suma de todos los
datos a la suma de los datos de la suma
de los datos ya esto dividiéndolo entre
el número el número de datos así sacamos
un promedio está de acuerdo ahora si yo
digo que en el primer salón de clases en
el primer set donde clases el promedio
70 el promedio 70 esto quiere decir que
es lo mismo que la suma de los datos la
suma de cada uno de los puntajes de los
alumnos de este primer salón del salón
que tiene estudiantes entre la cantidad
de datos pero la cantidad de datos sobre
la cantidad de estudiantes la cantidad
de estudiantes de este salón es p
ok de aquí pudo despejar a la suma me va
a quedar que la suma es igual a 70 p ok
hasta aquí creo que no hay bronca ahora
pensamos en el segundo salón en el
segundo salón pasa algo parecido estamos
diciendo que el 92 es igual a la suma de
la cantidad de datos oa la suma de los
puntajes del examen de cada uno de los
estudiantes entre entre la cantidad de
estudiantes que son n o dicho de otra
manera en este caso en el segundo salón
la suma es igual a 92 x en 92
ok y esto para que déjenme borrar un
poco esto para tener espacio de borrar
esto para tener un poco de espacio todo
esto te lo estoy diciendo por la
siguiente razón qué te parece si ahora
nos tomamos la suma la suma de todos los
datos de los estudiantes que están en el
segundo salón ya esto le voy a sumar la
suma
de todos los estudiantes que están en el
otro salón ya esto lo voy a dividir
entre la cantidad de estudiantes totales
que es n n más p más pp que obtendría de
esto bueno pues tengo toda la suma de
todos los datos de todos los puntajes de
los exámenes del segundo salón más toda
la suma de todos los datos de todos los
puntajes del examen del primer salón y
todo esto no dividido entre n más
estaría obteniendo un promedio total un
promedio de los dos salones un promedio
total ok lo padre es que me dicen que
este promedio total es 86 puntos es la
tercera parte de este problema cuando el
promedio de las dos clases se combina en
nuestro promedio total es 86 y lo que me
preguntan es cuánto es p / n ok esto más
espacio así que déjame ver si puedo
hacer esto para abajo
tomemos esto y volvamos lo para abajo un
poco ok ya tengo más espacio y ahora sí
sigamos trabajando porque porque me voy
a quedar con esto de aquí que es
bastante importante fíjate bien en esto
y en esto yo sé que la suma de los datos
de el primer salón del segundo salón es
igual a 92n por lo tanto lo voy a
sustituir aquí en lugar de poner la suma
de color amarillo voy a poner 92 en 92 m
justo aquí entonces me va a quedar
92 n más y en lugar de esta suma de
verde voy a sustituirla por este valor
que tengo aquí que es 70 p entonces 92 n
70 p ya esto lo voy a dividir entre la
cantidad de datos totales que es el más
p
esto tiene que ser igual a 86 y qué te
parece si de esta ecuación que ya por
fin encontramos esta ecuación
encontramos el valor de p / n ahora para
esto lo primero que voy a hacer es
multiplicar de ambos lados por n más p y
me va a quedar que 92 n más 70 p es
igual a 86 que multiplica a además p
además p
y ahora multiplicamos este por este y
éste por este que me va a quedar 92 n
más 70 p esto es igual a 86 m 86 p ok y
ahora contemos a todas las veces de este
lado por aquí voy a dejar todo lo que
tenga que ver con penn y todo lo que
tenga que ver con n de este lado y me va
a quedar 92 n y esto lo voy a pasar este
lado menos 86 n eso tiene que ser igual
aquí
bueno pues de este lado tengo 86 pero 86
pero ya esto le voy a quitar a 70 p 70
pero déjame ponerlo así
ok y cuántos esto
92-86 es lo mismo que 66 n es igual a 86
menos 70 es 16 16 pero
ahora jajaja ya casi encontramos la
respuesta si lo que quiero es p / n p /
n qué te parece si divido entre en ambos
lados de esta ecuación me va a quedar
que 6 es igual a 16 que multiplica ap /
n y ahora estoy dividido de ambos lados
entre 16 me va a quedar que 6 sobre 16
es igual ap / n que era justo lo que yo
quería p / n es 6 entre 16 que por
cierto 6 entre 16 es lo mismo que 3 /
org y esa es mi respuesta tres octavos
así que esa es la respuesta de este
último problema
la respuesta es tres octavos y por
cierto es el último problema de esta
sección así que nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo con una nueva sección
hasta la próxima